hey guys we're here with an official
character breakdown for Gorilla Grodd
and injustice - now this was taken
directly from another round live stream
so if you see something weird remember
that it's a work in progress and don't
forget to Like and subscribe to keep up
with all of our injustice to coverage
super strong super smart he's agile and
he's got some psionic abilities he's
like the total package in a way so so
he's like me but I don't know about that
but I guess stealing my jump you saw
where I was going with that that's what
so looks like 800 pounds you know he's
not a trained fighter like Batman is
right he's more animalistic and wild
obviously as a gorilla but we wanted to
translate that in his moves as well so a
lot of his moves are like these full
body motions really kind of primal and
like rayji type moves along with his
strength like he also feels because he's
so smart that he is so much better than
these opponents so he kind of wants to
just not only hit them and move just
destroy but pure dominance is what he
wants to do and it's a really cool line
you're going through because he's very
strong and powerful in feral Elmo's yeah
but he's also very smart exactly two
different ways to play right so let's uh
would it work together
absolutely and you'll see him shine uh
within like the medium to close range
you know he's really got some good tools
to kind of get him close because he's
not really a zone ER type guy he's brush
down more or less or just kind of just
get in your face so you know we could
see some of those moves right let's do
it let's talk about so we're we'll start
with sort of his some of the strings he
has that ability his normal attacks are
really cool because a lot of them
involve grabs and throws absolutely an
be meter absolutely yeah
so let's start with something like we
have the this one's super awesome I love
this yeah how's that and chews them out
this is you know feral right there right
he's like
his face which can also be burned
amongst anthem over you it's wrong
peaceful awesome I think you'd be
offended by that he might be he also has
where else we got do the two to three to
two to three is amazing the bite again
real quick and these are all just good
rush down maneuvers this pushes it back
right a great push back way over and the
one away bro and just like you're saying
people if he's swinging those arms
around like Epson which was giving him
also good reach on some attacks as well
too which is great
now that's as standard three that's a
three hand right that was pretty cool
and it look lined up the real quick that
my favorite movie has you can just show
which is the the clothesline right right
but you can also remember the close-up
manliness the combo disco they all don't
you hate you suit everybody and then
finisher got monkey brush right he does
doesn't he doesn't care be there in the
big bruiser yeah once he gets in you're
in trouble but so keeping him out is a
great absolutely but he's got tools to
get in yeah stuff he doesn't monkey
around oh wow ah all right all right
moving on one my favorite moves is like
it's not like a combo mover but one
thing I really to do is back to yeah
it's a really good it's good utility a
nice range to it and it also kind of
gives a little staggers and
it's not a combo but like you can really
make people up that way
absolutely that's something that people
don't know is thing we call in the
building the secret suite commands it
down one right there's a little toe it's
pretty quick too it also has coops elite
he also has a leave tonight which is a
secret suite
yes he can also go yeah further with his
sweep by lunging at the opponent it's
great right there's a good long reaching
Street Austin let's discuss a little bit
of some of your special moves yes
absolutely so let's do the Stampede
since we kind of saw that right you know
this is really good if you're if you're
far away and you really want to get
close the nice thing about this is you
can cancel this a tenth right so I can
oh it's a good move for players who play
this game because the way it kind of
resembles a little slower - so you might
confuse feel like you're getting dashing
or not if so then you can do like do
something like this come in and once
come in cancel and then give it a throw
or they secret sweep or secret suite
them which is important there it is but
it's really nice as if you need to burn
that he really picked up to speed
I'll get this opponent real quick and
then if he hit some you know you do this
like right pretty vicious combo yes
yes much better yeah cool good much
faster so that's that's a great move
room well sweet we go through here oh we
could talk about the leaf that's another
good one to get close but he can hit
hugely but you can do from difference
yeah you can push back report to kind of
change the distance on it how far he
goes and during while he's airborne you
can press one of your kind of your face
buttons to do a different attack with
your ears experinces yeah but it's all
either tell me more I can do
like with too close I didn't do rights
alright yeah that's the throw button
right which also another I mean this guy
if you have some meter you've got to do
some damage that's alright because he
can also flip them up too yep
for for some more continuation so great
he also has a ground pound oh right it's
a pretty short range move but if you're
pretty far away you really want to hook
the guy you can either bring that and it
travels fullscreen and you see the link
to the ground sort of lifts that's also
effects team effects they Owen back to
go again I also like just doing things
you know like when whistle is is a real
good mix of cool too and for the most
part - with Brad you're going to law to
your combos that end with me to your
opponent next yours
clora as possible right and so ending it
with that ground tom is really good so
that you can get back on right
absolutely we've been getting shoulders
just just this is throw this is my
favorite food yes throw is just in so
gorilla grodd yeah so guerrilla grub and
that's also shoutouts to come doc we
want to wear standard you get to see
here - no we're not shown this leads
been some trailers okay then here it is
got dr. everybody
who um talked about his trait is trait
yeah his his character power so here it
is he gains a psionic powers here so a
couple of his you get some new strings
some of those here we go yeah so first
to throw another your face great that's
a good combo ender what you have that
one yes sure and then towards to one yep
and then also kind of from here he gets
the ability to do mine crucial which I
showed which is yeah this is cool
because if you need to burn that you can
just run in you got this huge advantage
it makes them hit themselves absolutely
which is amazing and it gives you a
special power that's got really good
reach you know right so I mean you can
get them from a good distance mind
control and rush up and go into combo if
you're kind of stuck in that medium zone
that will occur a little bit worth of
that he also has a psionic lift that's a
good one yeah thanks thanks is this that
is we're talking another one done
everyone
so from here he has this like mode where
he has this little floating ability from
there you can kind of dash forward or
back to to gain some ability right but
you know you can cancel out of that
either by pressing dumb down or if you
want to do like a medium-range burst
press one that's the wrong mode that's
fine
so one that's really nice because it's
pretty quick and it hits really far
right so you could kind of - pass and
then hit the one and then you cross them
up in the new stuff - is the ground
pound there and you can either burn that
what I really like about the meter burn
is it's full screen pop up so you can be
really far away
be up in the air come down and do
something like yeah exactly and knock
them down get in the or do whatever you
want to do right now but let's say you
really have a problem with the guns
owners as big characters they do
definitely fair enough like if there's
not enough tools for him and someone's
just really like fire volunteer whatever
whatever at you if you turn on your
trait and then you have this down three
savage strength move you'll be
projectiles for like quite a long time
and then that gets him back in so you're
you're getting zoned out here turn it on
and I'm just walking in oh yeah yeah
that's a pretty powerful right now it
only lasts you know a certain amount of
seconds and it only happens with his
traits on Chronos you gotta take your
timings yes so definitely a super cool
character I've been playing with him a
lot we had some matches we have a lot of
fun with earlier odd awesome question is
super we always super right let's do it
his super sausage is just like
straight-up brew yeah and he uses both
brains and brawn different so we'll see
that oh you how did you okay that I'd
answer I don't think you can
[Music]
shows that animal side of them you still
animal on the inside hey debo 3:05 on
twitch just said I found my main
everyone's everyone seems to be really
enjoying bro gonna do great
so good for you so you know what maybe
we should show them some more stuff then
oh we got we just and cool cool gear
setups ready to go let's do it
I love you won't work on better okay so
I go to you will always do it wrong
there you go wrong huh there it is
there we go you guys show off the way to
some of its utility oh oh right oh right
right in there so first off you want to
flip stansson there we go this amazing
like so right golden with the we got the
green horn they're pretty Ozzy emerald
horn emerald gets its emerald I've home
that's alright I mean he's royalty we
were talking with it they way to yeah
well like this is really cool so you can
actually like do the sort of thing and
then resend yeah which is which is
important to his game yes exactly
there are also combos which they're
doing in QA I can I can't do one today
but it's because it's a little
challenging for me I'm getting there
where you can actually set this up into
a we have seen I actually just just just
did it so that's really cool Lily did it
on the cross up ba-leep yeah did this
one here music yeah yeah you so is his
two spins around so you can actually
cross up with it real easily and then
jump over them and cross up to so he's
got a lot of fun tools let's check out
some of the wood which moves did I did I
add here I don't know I got you probably
isn't a new combo is this the air tie
let's see let's try this
no no Steve wrote them down we're going
to find them real quick hmm unless we
somehow didn't get them put in well you
know oh right
let's see I don't think I put in
actually that we may have a mistake and
not having put in so that's not on that
Burke that's on that's on me
anybody look anyway still blame me for
it we will blame Burke for that let's
take a look at another one of his uh
sweet tweet costumes absolutely uh else
does he have there's some really cool
this this one is this is next one's my
favorite one take a look here
I like some schoolboy ideas and crazy
stuff that's what I usually wear on the
weekends right and spikes so just so he
has a really neat here um yeah they do
think they did not say so um well either
way we got awesome looking gear for
Grodd right he's got a lot of really
great abilities that he has as well so
like one of them that we were not being
able to furnish oh this is an Tiger when
she does help out for his game so he's
able to do these anti-air grab you
actually my favorite thing which will
they will try to get a gift ready of
that is his throw he can actually meet a
brute and hit and swing swing swing
board or just keep you pretty ridiculous
yeah that's awesome so he does have a
lot of cool just more stuff to get in
there new damage I'm sorry we're in I
will show you all those I I messed up
that's on me that's not on man quit
he'll Matt way to go Matt Matt nice job
you know maybe we can put out a nice
trailer right but we can't hear you
again so Pete anything else you want to
talk about brillig rod no I think he's